o sangue achado na implementação de uma
cadeia positiva do evento do futebol
russo
bom eu tô aqui vamos pra falar sobre um
dos temas mais importantes da nossa
nossa espécie nosso planeta que a nossa
relação com o alimento com alimentação 1
a 4 se alimentar a gente a gente bota
três vezes por dia por pelo menos duas
vezes por dia e aos principais e mais
ações quando a gente pensa em mudança
será mais um ponto positivo muito bem
criando pontos é alinhar que significa
alimentos estão muito e os alimentos mas
aqui qual é o significado de se ter um
alimento alimentos significa curar a
cuidar no tempo alimentar que vai muito
além de muitas vezes na maioria das
vezes a gente encontra disponível é
verdade que embora o alimento ea
orientação de que esteja na nossa vida
não seja um dos comportamentos mais
ancestrais instintivos na história da
humanidade a gente pouco conhece um
pouco sabe sobre o alimento como pensa
sobre a forma que a gente se alimenta a
gente é uma série de coisas no dia a dia
como por exemplo a gasolina o
combustível tem que colocar nosso carro
mas
jogamos pra deus nosso hora pode você é
mais um bom ea verdade assim se a gente
não pensa que a gente colhe quem estava
se alimentando de que tipo de alimento
tão sendo oferecido
a história mostra que nós fomos de
caçadores-coletores nós assentados
hoje 50 anos na gestão e nos
movimentamos - a nossa vida hoje é mais
conveniente do que nunca aliás tem um
sangue nos olhos que são lugares do
mundo são sete lugares no mundo onde a
samsung tem mais centenários por
habitante é um dos principais fatores a
conveniência é aquela coisa tirar o
controle remoto lá trocar o canal de
televisão net você se acostumando a ter
uma vida mais moderno ambiente e se
encomenda e consumindo mais calorias de
rendimentos de menor valor nutritivo
na verdade que hoje a gente for olhar o
mundo risco dado pelo exagero no consumo
é menor do que da escassez fazer um
breve relato sobre o alimento só para a
gente entender como o iphone é que isso
aconteceu até 1900 a relação à nossa
relação com a terra o alinhamento
adquirir as famílias plantavam plantavam
e colhiam inclusive a vão próprio
eventos que não existia a filosofias
modismos nos bandidos senhora a senhora
não era aberta pelo tema
elster voltará a assistir uma aula sobre
alimentação de professores campo
acompanhando o próprio um alimento
industrializado então é jóia alimento
industrializado os ingredientes e têm lá
20 30 40 emergentes muitos deles ea
gente não consegue produzir a onu
aliás mais bola disse que sua voz não
soube a conhecer um alimento não forma
que certamente não é bom mas ele estava
comparando dizia assim o alimento
industrializado e assim tantos
ingredientes ingredientes leite a cimpor
antes estabilizantes conservantes enfim
e quando ia posto os nutrientes eram
calorias vazias praticamente nada
culturas ruins
ele comparou o próprio próprio
ingredientes e nutrientes potássio
cálcio é uma série de novelas estão
alimentos de verdade inclusive a
margarina quando na época isso faço um
fórum foi criada o movimento queria que
ela quer cuidar de rosa para que ela
para que as pessoas tomassem
conhecimento soubesse que não é
identificar se o blog tudo mais não
passou mas a realidade que não é miguel
copa de 1930 o alimento papel já uma das
estâncias relatar congelar adiciona mais
sal e açúcar nos alimentos foram a seus
métodos encontrados naquela época e até
muito utilizado até hoje para garantir a
conservação
por que ele pudesse chegar a lugares
distantes com a revolução verde à medida
que a população foi crescendo e
revolução verde excelente modificadas
foi quando surgiram as sementes
modificadas a novas tecnologias de
produção de alimentos
os defensivos químicos e com isso foi
possível alimentar a população que vê um
crescimento bastante acelerado soja a
milho pecuária foi um sonho dele e agora
passaram a tomar uma predominância no
mercado do campo al awfi a 1970 um marco
importante
a mulher sai da cozinha e conquistar o
mercado de trabalho é quem ocupa um
lugar
a indústria foi a foi um marco na
surgimento do alimento conhece
foi quando nasceu a marca começou
descongelado de todo alimento por
conveniência na vi nada tentativa de
facilitar uma vida que passou a ser
colhida na verdade que os dois nós
passamos dez mil anos correndo atrás do
alimento que agora a gente quer o que
procura que este custo é uma comida
fácil barata e saborosa
não tem nada de errado você faça uma ex
namorada é o problema é que elas sempre
um geralmente predomínio de calorias
vezes há aqui tem algumas não tá ficou
mesmo assim alguns elementos que a vida
moderna nos fez buscar é a falta de
tempo ao fracasso de alimentos
industrializados para estética produtos
diet light de águas milagrosas para a
falta de vitaminas e suplementos para
diabetes adoçantes e para a hipertensão
remédios são verdadeiros rendimentos da
nossa vida da vida moderna e hoje a
gente vive
o mundo é menor que utilizariam o a
realidade aqui a forma como hoje a gente
alimenta 7 bilhões de pessoas no mundo
têm sustentável em dia é quem tem a
oportunidade de italianos sobre esse
tema sérgio ramos 15 anos é maior claro
que tem um outro que é o rock também
fala sobre isso que há a dificuldade de
estudo de manter o modelo atual de
consumo predominantemente de alimentos
que a gente pensa no futuro das gerações
alguns dados a de 2016 os mais recentes
por exemplo 28 milhões de mortes no
mundo inteiro quando está associado a
uma alimentação mais da metade da
população brasileira sofre com sobrepeso
60% de diabetes aumentou nos últimos dez
anos no brasil 80% das doenças crônicas
de fato poderiam ser evitados inclusive
diabetes com uma boa atuação
estudos recentes dizem que já nasceram
quando chegamos no ator que já nasce uma
relação que pode haver menos que seus
pais não saber se alimentar ea verdade é
que a nossa escolha coloca em risco
também outro grande organismo que o meio
ambiente
o solo degradado que a gente olha o solo
ele já não é mais o mesmo sol tinha
antigamente já não produz o alimento com
a mesma qualidade na gestão da pecuária
o consumo excessivo de carne faz dela os
principais emissores senão o principal
emissor de efeitos de gases de efeito
estufa no mundo todo
todos os meios de transporte somados
fica apenas a casa da produção de
energia é 70% da água potável do planeta
é proveniente da agricultura e 70% da
contaminação da água potável também é
proveniente de culturas utilizadas 70
por cento pelo youtube a convenção
também na fábrica nos últimos 50 anos
um quinto da floresta amazônica foi o
sinal foi dizimada e 60% da população
das espécies mamíferas as faces répteis
e anfíbios declinaram em 1.170
indicadores principal fator disso é aaa
à demanda crescente na portela ea água e
acaba ea produção de alimentos muito bem
tirando agora toda a partir na trágica e
jordaniana acreditem se confrontar como
a gente muda isso
o primeiro trabalhador motivo o consumo
a gente precisa na nossa alimentação
diária aumentar a quantidade de plantas
do nosso prato é uma realidade decisão
em transplantes aumentar a entrada de
adriano buscar um milhão de verdade
preferencialmente de algum produtor que
ficou menos intenso do que a gente
produz é desperdiçado ou nos processos
logísticos ou mesmo estamos produção com
os dos restaurantes
as casas intenso do alimento produzido
no mundo
agora é algo mas alguns exemplos
importantes para que a influência da
mudança de natação escalar método de
agricultura positiva e cultura linha
orgânica é responsável nosso restaurante
2008 61 toneladas de alimento limpo foi
consumido no ano de 2018 reduzir a
distância entre o cultivo eo consumo
gente tem um movimento mais intenso e um
desperdício menor ano de 2008 53
toneladas foram consumidos do celular
pequeno produtor analise e agricultura
familiar
esse é outro fator fundamental que a
gente pensa uma alimentação mais rica
com alimentação mas inter incluir mais
plantas do dia a dia das pessoas
a urbam a dell churrasco formais cenho
que refeições à base de plantas
consumidas tornar o alimento livro
acessível quando nós compramos alimento
orgânico direto do produtor em feiras de
produtores nós em 70 e 80 por cento dos
casos é até maio o quilo de 80 é mais
barato é assim que o alimento
convencional comprar no supermercado
então alimentou o cara que tivesse um
mercado que parece tão caro quanto ele é
comprar um produtor
ele era maioria das vezes mais acessível
um bom tempo é importante também é a
todos nós pegamos ou não vegetarianos
independente condições e produtivista
trazer mais pessoas e levantar bandeira
uma alimentação responsável orientação
positiva a elevar a informação
consistente mas convido vocês a
participar já está lançando o
documentário sobre o futuro da
alimentação chance que você vai poder
amanhã o primeiro episódio vai ser
lançado em junho e valeu a informação
sobre isso com o impacto do alimento na
nossa vida é e como a gente pode buscar
soluções para alimentar melhor
por fim é justo dizer que todos os
empresários do segmento de alimentação
médico nutricionista seus profissionais
da área na cidade são todos notam os
nossos profissionais empreendedores da
saúde tem que mudar essa visão e dono de
restaurante faz prato refeições o que
isso tem a certeza vem de alimentos em
todo o nosso estado base em jogos com
saúde do motivo o cônsul jorge neuss não
nutriam alimentar sustentar e cuidar não
era em anos
obrigado
[Aplausos]